qui arrive un moment où elles sont
consentantes
elle a besoin d'amour de tendresse
[Musique]
vous avez déjà violé des femmes
oui vous avez déjà violé une femme n'ont
jamais vous est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
envie de violer une femme oui d'une
certaine façon sa femme est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu envie de violer une femme à
non non non ah non jamais jamais non
elles sont nombreuses qui sont les
femmes qui se font violer
celles qui sont imprudents
les aguicheuses ça dépend de leur tenue
vestimentaire
celle qui veut le bien qui sont les
femmes qui sont violées
à mon avis ça peut être n'importe quelle
femme est beaucoup plus que ce qu'on
pense sir entendre des fois oui stèle
femme elle l'a cherché tout non je pense
que ça peut vraiment concerné tout le
monde les plus jeunes jimmy mois toutes
les phases
il n'y a pas de parti tu arrivé il n'y a
pas un profit ce violeur avance en avant
tout je pense là bas je crois que ça
peut être n'importe quelle femme c'est
juste une question d'hommes en fait est
ce que toutes les femmes ont envie de se
faire violer je pense oui
sincèrement oui est ce que les femmes l
envie de se faire violer oh non c'est
pas possible
femme-là besoin d'amour de tendresse on
est en dessous faire violer c'est de la
violence et à partir des extraterrestres
[Musique]